nous sommes venus ici aujourd'hui chez
pierre paulin le benjamin des
entraîneurs de maisons laffitte
justement pour vous percevoir trois des
chevaux qui ont de bonnes chances de
gagner le grand prix de pertes ce chemin
là vous avez théâtre en partance pour
les rives et cliquer pour voir d'abord
faire appel
il attirait alors voulez-vous nous le
faire venir sera zen j'en profite pour
vous présenter madame del duca la
charmante propriétaire et massa et à
monter dans de gros gagnants aux courses
alors ça c'est sa part à 13 il a fini 2e
l'autre jour dans le prix jockey club
mais il se met sur 2400 mètres et
dimanche sans chasse trois mille 3000
rick alors 600 mètres le plus souvent
qu'on soit ça sera bien pour lui ce sera
bien pour lui après bien lui et le
terrain vous auriez préféré à terrain
loué voulait pas de préférence
comme tous les bons chevaux et leurs
emplettes et voilà ici alors maintenant
madame dame du cajou vrai que vous nous
disiez si google maps ou deux chevaux
dans son prix oui on sent bien que cette
éclosion que vous avez refusé lundi
alors voulez-vous faire venir un black
éclosion devant la caméra de l'athénée
anbya que celui qui a gagné le prix
d'art eu à longchamp il ya environ un
mois
brillamment cinq six longueurs mais
dimanche dernier à chantilly chebouki le
monde alors pour lui vous préféreriez
que le terrain soit plus sous mon trait
noir diax à la valeur bien
oui et alors l'autre c'est notre c'est
claudio claudio et lequel préférez-vous
ddv l'âme alors on va demander à massari
ce que vous avez le choix des mots que
vous avez courant bias et vous monsieur
pierre fulla c'est bien votre avis on
regarde les obtenir mais gaudet alors je
vous propose d'aller sur le terrain de
faire galoper les trois chevaux pour
essayer de montrer aux téléspectateurs
celui qui est le meilleur
ça va comme cela mais alors nous nous
rendons maintenant sur le terrain